[Music]
if you go to vimeo.com z-- staff pics
page you'll find several short films
that play in the same meticulously
designed weird art house thriller space
as Jonathan Glaser's under the skin
you see that kind of thing on the web
more than you do in the theater because
supreme ambiguity as a cinematic
category rarely attracts investment the
reason for this is contemptible but
obvious the lack of explanation or
closure is painful it hurts as M John
Harrison says if there appears to be a
factor of that process and unwillingness
to serve up that failure to filmgoers
that pain that anxiety has ruled
Hollywood from the start so ideas like
these find a home on the web which
embraces everything art house shorts are
potent because their brief 20 minutes of
the very longest happy to contain a
single question to be a single question
what makes under the skin so special is
that it maintains this same potency
across 108 minutes the movie follows
Scarlett Johansson as Laura a blank face
but beautiful alien as she follows and
ensnares young men who are never to be
seen or heard from again
watching listless Lee at the beach as a
couple and their dog drown in a strong
undertow it's made clear that Laura does
not possess a traditional set of morals
if any at all a few compatriot aliens
with speed bikes act as a cleanup crew
for her nocturnal activities and make
sure she keeps on schedule plot wise
that's pretty much it the interactions
between Laura and her victims are tense
and gripping in between Glazer treats us
too long
carefully frame takes of pedestrians at
shopping centers or Johansson's face
filmmakers hold on images so you can
examine them if you see this film in
theaters be sure to let your eyes wander
I was struck by the depth of the
Scottish landscapes the camera always
sure to have elements in the four middle
and background more three-dimensional
than anything you need glasses for
particularly when contrasted with the
repetitious camerawork laser used to
capture real Scots from the window of
Laura's nondescript white van peppered
throughout is imagery of a more surreal
variety evoke in Kubrick at times mostly
in its boldness and not as much as the
trailer suggests strung together by the
perfect screening score of Myka levy
then toward the end of the film
Laura's inhumanity begins to peel back
just in time for Humanity to show its
darkest side we finally glimpse what's
under the skin but as she or it an alien
the Michel Faber novel on which under
the skin is based says so even Glaser
whose adaptation runs far afield of the
source material has said explicitly that
Johansson's character is otherworldly
taking the film as it is however I'm not
so sure there's no question that Laura
is alien and all that adjective means
unfamiliar disturbing distasteful it's
impossible to parse her motivations
except for in the broadest strokes he or
to the novel goes into much much more
detail but I'm wary to identify anything
that the film itself doesn't choose to
maybe laura is just the demonstration of
a feeling an embodiment of all in nature
that is ravenous but disinterested or
just the idea of disinterest set loose
in the locks and under toes of human
yearning even this I'm afraid is saying
too much art house movies are
unapologetic in their use of cinemas
unique toolbox as a medium of light and
sound of imagery film is an innately
ambiguous language filmmakers like
Glaser no doubt express their vision in
this form because actual language wasn't
up to their task why then should we try
to bring movies like under the skin back
to the page it works so hard to
transcend because the alternative is
pain that vast ambiguous space like a
dark empty room where you can be
ensnared by something ibaka t'v ensnared
and suddenly consumed
never learning why
[Music]